[Music]
I'm no speech giver I'm just a regular
guy who keeps the stretch of
civilization open but I really am
honored to be named citizen of the year
[Music]
yeah it's about your son Hayes dad oh
[Music]
you got mixed up with some drug dealer
by the name of Mike King whose [ __ ]
Vikings a whole different breed Jenna
what a bully is I gave you Lord of the
Flies all the answers are in that book
I'm gonna kill these guys really what
makes you think you can kill a man I
read it no crime novel
[Music]
three of vikings dealers have
disappeared state of limbo Sam yeah what
is with all these nicknames pedo Vikings
a gangster
did you have a nickname wingman wingman
yeah from Top Gun as in you can be my
wingman
one guy can disappear would you be
someone wants me dead my guess it was
white ball white ball is Vikings rival
it's white bull wants war and I'll give
it to him
oh Jesus we had a turf war right here in
the town this doesn't happen in Kia just
dead
you have gone as far as you're gonna go
this is my world now
I don't think it does
I will have blood for blood
thank you a kidnapping on all the time
you drive the same road day after day
it's easy to think about the road not
taken
but I picked a good road and I stayed on
it
knows cocksman citizen dear
good for him
[Music]
we need rose tonight I'm sorry you need
a reservation excuse me Reza do you have
any idea what I can do to you on
TripAdvisor
[Music]
you